many generations ago spirits lived
amongst humankind protecting them from
the dangers of the world the trouble is
the world has changed and eventually
humans forgot the spirits existed I play
the storyteller it's still believing in
guardian spirits huh yeah I play Lully
she's a pragmatic mother who wants the
best for her daughter maybe the spirits
will help us rain wants to believe in
the spirit world and she's not gonna
stop until she figures it out two of
these spirits were the Guardian brothers
we're Guardians not gardeners all grow
up I play one of the two guardian
brothers you a Gentoo look at all these
lanterns the humans must be asking us
for help the humans don't like us
anymore for all we know that some kind
of booby trap they feel like the humans
have forgotten this does not look good
the world is turning upside down it's
the knee end huh and the end is an
ancient and evil shape-shifter seeking
to conquer both the human and spirit
world
Oh
by working together could we conquer
this evil
it has Abbot's both our worlds it's
about old and new tradition versus being
able to change its a mythic adventure
story
[Music]
cookies
almost a standard ELISA we're done here
I'm going clubbing